hello everyone how are you all doing
today
we will be starting this session in 10
more minutes
at 5 00 pm indian standard time
so thank you for joining and the chat
box is open for any questions
so i welcome you all to this session
please post any questions that you may
have
and we will be talking soon and sharing
with you
all about engis in a moment
we will be starting here in three more
minutes and we'll wait for participants
to join in today
thank you
so just as we are starting the program
and i'm receiving questions
in the chat box from some of you i want
to address that we will be addressing
some of the research questions
as well today in this program and talk
about
the different aspects of rna-seq
analysis
and if you have any questions related to
both the training
as well as the research program please
continue to post them in the chat
besides myself we also have our team
present here
so they will be able to answer any kind
of questions you have related to either
training in bioinformatics as well as
bioinformatics research or
bioinformatics projects
which we are going to address at length
today so thank you again
and we are going to be starting the
session in one more minute
and i'm also putting down my email id in
the chat for
anybody who may have these specific
questions
especially related to research and you
can reach out to me there
thank you
welcome to this free webinar on ngs data
analysis
today we will discuss about the upcoming
training program
and the various aspects of rnac data
analysis and how this field
of bioinformatics continues to evolve
this special program has been designed
for students faculty
and researchers in this program we will
focus
on one type of data which is
transcriptomics data
this program will cover analysis of gene
expression data
with practical sessions and online
tutorials
anyone with a basic knowledge of cell
and molecular biology
will be able to conceptually understand
as well as practically apply standard
data analysis
tools to process analyze and interpret
complex
transcriptomics data together we will
study
analytical approaches for rna-seq data
using bioinformatics methods and
databases
we will be able to use rna-seq data to
study
gene and isoform expressions in various
organisms across many conditions
so the omics logic programs are a result
of close collaboration between pi and
biotech
and innovative big data and analytics
company based
in the us and numerous academic
institutions
that have participated in content
evaluation curriculum review and project
design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly tested
around the world and are known to lead
to excellent outcomes for students with
minimal bioinformatics background
including biology
and biomedical studies majors as well as
faculty
interested in bioinformatics data
science
and biomedical research in the last
omics logic transcriptomics program
which we had in 2020
many participants joining us were able
to successfully complete
the program and the feedback shared by
these participants are encouraging for
our team as well as those who continue
to take these courses the participant
feedback also demonstrates that the
learning
is effective and even transformational
the training is offered using and
leveraging the regular
online webinars like we're having today
practical exercises and online courses
these resources
provide a broad and detailed overview
of processing statistical analysis
machine learning tools and single cell
data analysis techniques
the courses cover methods expand on
various terminologies provide practical
examples
and offer quizzes for self evaluation
while we use the server platform for
running
pipelines and the core omix logic
platform for learning more about
rn python and its utility in
understanding
bioinformatics data my name is vipsha
biswas
and i am the omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
who are part of our community before i
introduce everyone to the team behind
omics logic and today's session speakers
we would like to know more about you so
right now
on your screen you will see a poll
so here are a few questions what we want
to learn
from you about your understanding of ngs
so the first question is
what are your interests in learning ngs
data analysis
and you can choose from the four
different
options that you see on your screen
the second question is what research
area i'm sorry it's written where
what research area you want to apply ngs
transcriptomics data analysis
to so these are a few areas if you see
that
there is an answer and you would want to
apply to any other area which you have
not mentioned beyond
these four please put them down in the
chat box so that we are aware
that the different research areas you
are interested in
so i see that a lot of you are
interested in precision oncology
very interesting as well as infectious
diseases
so how much time will you be able to
dedicate for the
ngs data analysis training per week
okay so i think we are having six to
eight hours is the highest number
and what ngs data analysis research you
are familiar with
so there's single cell transcriptomics
non-coding rna
mrna and i'm a beginner and would like
to learn more
okay so i see that today we have a lot
of you who are just starting out
with learning about ngs data analysis
which is interesting and we will be
covering some of these
important aspects as well so i'll just
leave on
this poll for one more minute and
then we'll move ahead with the
presentation
so if you have not yet answered please
go ahead with the poll and i'll be
ending the poll in a minute
okay thank you everybody
i'm honored to have been working with a
team
that collectively have amazing
experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company
dr alfred tober comes from a medical
background with
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of inflammation and has a
long-standing recognition
for his generous support of many
international projects and research
activities
one of these projects is the
establishment of the topper
bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
here at prime biotech
and here you can meet the other members
of our team
as well as dr leonid brodsky
in the upcoming one month period you
will have the opportunity to interact
and collaborate with an international
team of experts
specialized in the areas of
bioinformatics and data-driven research
let me introduce you to the program
mentors we have dr harpreet kaur
who is our omics logic trainer and
expert bioinformatician and she will
mentor sessions and guide participants
throughout the programs her area of
specialization is in cancer genomics we
will be hearing more from dr
cord today dr mohit mazumdar has a phd
in computational biology and over 10
years of
experience working with industry and
academia
elia brodsky is our ceo and co-founder
his experience in research in academia
has led to many research labs and
university collaborations and has been
recognized for the simplified approach
to omits analysis for
education now i would like to invite dr
mazumdar
to talk more about rna-seq analysis and
ngs data thank you dr muzumdar over to
you
yeah thank you biepcha let me share my
screen
hello everyone and thank you for joining
this specialized session on
bioinformatics omix logic technology
my name is mohit mazumdar and in my
current role i'm working and
collaborating with universities in asia
and africa
to introduce innovative curriculums on
data driven biological research
at different level of education so
during this short period i've been
honored to be able to collaborate and
work with thousands of students and
researchers around the globe
so this free webinar is conducted for
participants
and especially students and researchers
and faculty in
india and neighboring countries we have
invited
all who have shown interest in learning
about
ngs transcriptomics data analysis and
research
using our research program and platforms
in the context of the upcoming program
the online
training is a unique opportunity not
only to not only
learn about ngs transcriptomics but to
master data science skill sets
and apply to an original research
project
in in within two months of training so
let's
learn about this exciting field of
research so beepsha i
i'm facing an issue with uh slight
transitions
because i think the host uh co-hosting
thing
so can you check that so
as i was telling you that let's start
with learning about this technology
and to do that i mean let's answer a few
questions
so molecular biologists study
a broad spectrum of topics related to
regulations of cell biology from dna
and rna to protein expression and then
protein protein interactions
so next generation sequencing is a key
technology that is enabling which is
enabling us
at an unprecedented level of precision
and efficacy in understanding genomic
and transcriptomic
regulations so a next generation
a next generation sequencer
creates a digital file right and
that digital file represents a sequence
dna
or rna so this file contains
information where nucleotides are
represented
by letters uh corresponding to their
bases right
so a dominant theme in molecular biology
is how uh variation
how variation in nucleic acid
which is the genotype affects the
biology of the organism which is the
phenotype so a second major theme
in the study of gene expression and this
resulting chain
is observed transcriptomics features of
a studying
studying sample so what what is a
transcriptomic feature of our studying
sample
so in next generation sequencing data
analysis
uh where we call it like rna-seq a lot
of time
the purpose of this analysis is to map
the short reads from raw sequencing
files
to the reference genome and then study
the abundance of rna mapped to a
particular region
so this abundance can represents the
level
of gene or the isoform expression
and then it can be compared between
samples
or group of samples so that is uh
an overview about transcriptomics
and rna sequencing
so i'm still facing issue with the
transition
so in today's workshop we will start
with
big biological data and the high
throughput sequencing processes
which are focused on rna-seq ngs
data so to know more about this today
in this session we will go through
transcriptomics resources uh
then we will be talking about the mentor
support and we will be demonstrating you
and demonstrate to you the explanation
of methods
using multi-omics tbi info platform
so one of the major objective of this
entire you know methodology starting
from the courses
training support and then learning the
techniques
so this the major objective of this
research training
is to enable the participants to prepare
for
real-world application of rna-seq and to
be able to apply
training to a research project so the
uh how the overall project uh
works it can be summarized in a few
steps
so let me tell you about a few few steps
that we can take
to work on a project so how how does it
actually works
so it can start from you know framing a
problem which could be like a title of
your project
and then ident identifying a data set so
that data set
uh actually represents the research that
you're interested in
it could be agriculture like many of you
have shown
interest that was there in the poll that
uh
in agriculture applying it in
agriculture and
biomedical research or any other kind of
research
so from identifying a data set and the
references
to preparing the data next step is to
prepare the data
process the data for analysis and then
perform the analysis
so once your data is prepared the next
step would be to perform your analysis
and do uh go in depth of that what
what you are finding so whether your
process that process that you're
following is statistically correct
and logical and then you're trying to
interpret the results
so uh in this uh today's webinar
uh and as we are speaking about this uh
we will be having dr harpreet kaur
in a short time to talk more about
applying
ngs transcriptomics uh research in
translational
how it is how it is playing a key role
in translational research
which is uh uh boom in the
biomedical industry so now let me show
you
the design and the curriculum of the
first four week of the training
for first four weeks of the training
so the program uh will kick off on
second march
2021 and uh on the session
on that day we'll feature the
orientation orientation session
with our omix logic trainer dr harpreet
carr myself as the project man
mentor and along with that along with us
uh ms beepsha biswas and the team of
interns and research fellows
so during the first week we will learn
about
we will learn about uh processing of
gene expression
then we will learn about alternative
splicing
and then we will learn about assays for
mrna detection and quantification so
after
completing the introduction to next
generation sequencing
for study uh to study the rna expression
next we will learn about quantitative
and qualitative analysis of
rna in a sample and then data
preparation
using next generation sequencing and
preparation of
table of expression uh from raw fast q
files so all of our omics logic training
uh kind of includes uh resources
so these resources are assigned to each
sessions
to help student make the most out of
this training
so uh in this first
session we will be introducing you to a
lot of resources
so this omixlogic program
leverages our top-rated online tutorials
that are present
in this uh educational platform
so that includes uh so the program
participants
will have the access exclusive resources
that are assigned
for each session that
are associated with the training so
along with this
there is a smart tracking of activity
and there are curated data sets
biological
data sets that are designed for a great
learning experience
so after this we will be talking about
the analytical platform
so this program uh
and throughout this course
you will be given directions to access
the
t by info platform and i don't know if
you guys are able to see the animation
so we have to fix this picture can you
just
sign out and uh like sign in with
with your own login
bible can you hear me
okay sorry for this let's just
try to figure this out because
uh-huh are still having issue
so just uh for a second let me
login again the slide transitions
can be smooth because each time i'm
doing the transition
it's getting stuck so there are no
animations that could be played
with this so just let me sign in
and join again
so dr harpreet you're there yes yes i am
okay dr harpreet so i'm making you the
host
and i'm going to join again all right
okay
okay
so beeps i have made you co-host yeah
thank you
okay okay so
can you see it see my screen now yeah
yes okay perfect so
as i was telling you that uh throughout
this course uh we will be sending you
the directions
directives to access the t-bind for
platform so the t-pan for platform
uh have uh the processing area and
analysis
area for rna-seq data so the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management
and analysis cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipeline and different
stages of analysis
are performed in different sections of
this multi-omics platform
it's a quite comprehensive platform
which is used for
various sort of trainings we are
conducting oncology specialization
trainings
we are conducting um infectious disease
specialized
specialization trainings so these are
some of the uh
panels i have been um collaboratively
uh worked out with universities like
ucsf who uh with whom we have developed
this virology section
and so as you see there are several
sections here so in this program our
focus will be on the transcriptomic
section
so in this transcriptomic sections
section we will learn about
first we will learn about the data
processing and then
we will be using the section under data
mining
and we will there we will be learning
about different
algorithms which machine learning
algorithms
and classification uh algorithms
that that are going to help us
understand the meaning out of this
big omics data and again like when we
are integrating multiple data sets like
you talk about
uh the non-coding rnas and
mrna and then on other omics data then
we have
a dedicated section for multi-omics
integration as well
which is quite popular and gives a lot
of
insights that we were not been able to
get gain
before so um and then
we will be using so the other platform
that you saw
the tbi info platform that does not
require
any coding require you to do any coding
so you can learn
from a visual environment and learn
about the logic
of the analysis so the focus here is to
learn about the logic
that why these steps are used and what
are the
standard output from an uh popular
algorithms that are used for
rna-seq experiments and we will be
learning more about it
when dr harpreet takes you there so
we'll be
doing that in a in some time but to tell
you more about that how we are utilizing
this
in a synchronous way so that you
gain a deeper understanding of how this
sort of analysis
is done and applied in current research
so you start with the understanding of
the theory
and then we go into the practical
aspects of
doing the experiment and then after
doing the experiment
we would want to do a visualization and
we would want to do some downstream
analysis
so we have exercises designed to explain
the codes
for these types of visualization in both
r and python
that will be used in this program
so along with that uh we will be sending
you the video tutorials
and these video tutorials explain
different aspects of you know uh whether
we are going to
want to uh install python whether we
want to you know
do it on the on the platform whether how
do we want to you know
learn about the different sections of
the platform so
all those are uh already available and
video recorded
tutorials with us and we will be sharing
those with our participants
when we start the program so after that
the first introductory week where we
will be sharing you about the platform
getting you more familiarized with the
resources
and you are comfortable about you know
exploring and
going to the platform and having your
own profile
then the next week the next class
on march 5th we will start with the
analysis
and um to talk about the analysis
we will be doing after gaining a basic
understanding
we will start with a data set so there
is a significant
interest in sequencing especially
in the context of oncology and that is
due to its potential to
advance diagnostics and personalized
treatment
so that that added with that
there is an improvement on understanding
of
the treatment responses and the cause
and mechanism of tumor development so
all of these things
are contributing in precision oncology
so in this session using a breast cancer
uh data set
we will review we will be reviewing
methods how to
how data is generated using next
generation sequencing
and use a sample uh project patient
derived xenograft transcriptomics
biomarkers for breast cancer to practice
generating a table of expression from
raw fast q files
so from a publication that is
the data which is being published and
submitted in a ncbi bio project
we will be using that data set and we
will be giving you the publication
and we will be having this session to
describe that and we will
start working on the data and
understanding uh of
how from raw data you can generate
a table of expression
so in addition to the online courses uh
obviously all the participants will get
access to the hands-on exercises and
data sets for practice
uh these can be completed without any
coding so this will be by using the
t-band for platform
that will give you an interactive
learning experience
so uh talking about the transcriptomic
sequencing uh so this is a
transcriptomics uh pipeline
that has a number of algorithms that you
can see
so transcriptomic sequencing is a major
advance
in the study of gene expression in the
field of study of gene expression
because it allows a snapshot of whole
transcriptome
rather than a predetermined set of genes
so before that it was microarray we have
panels then we have set of genes
which were biomarkers now we can look at
the entire transcriptome at a given
point of time
to study this data right it's a lot of
data
to study this data we will learn about
processing pipelines
so this is a processing pipeline a
processing pipeline that turns
raw reads means the reads that are
coming from a sequencing machine
into structured data that which is ready
for analysis so this platform is color
coded
uh color coded means that section wise
you can
you know differentiate that which
section is
for which kind of analysis so this helps
to establish a logical connection
between
uh theoretical aspects of data analysis
methods
and uh the practical steps that are
needed to
achieve a biologically interpretable
result
so the pipeline outputs that we get so
once you get uh once you are done with
your once you run your analysis
and once you get uh from a table from
rod
sequence to a table of expression
so the pipeline outputs are offered as
tables
graphics and interactive visualization
helping users to understand the way data
can
be used to uh you know explore or
understand a biological phenomena
so we will also learn to preview and
visualize
the resulting data using principal
component analysis
so this is a very popular algorithm
which is a machine learning algorithm
which is used to visualize
uh high dimensional data
multi-dimensional data
so two per to perform the example
analysis
uh this will be uh also
uh provided that is also provided in the
course student will need to have the
access of the tbi info platform to
to do the assignment and then you will
get all these sort of uh
hands-on practical aspect of doing the
analysis so in this
entire training we will also be using
microsoft excel
or any other software equivalent
software
for plotting so this would also require
us to go to some of the uh ncbi
for example this is a jbrowse where you
can visualize
the alignment uh in much more detail
so after doing all of this in the first
week uh
the second week we will be learning
about
data preparation using ngs and getting
the table of expression from
raw fascio files so in the next session
we will review
important topics and keywords that are
associated with
rna-seq transcriptomics analysis so in
this session
we will learn about working with table
of expression
to get a high-level view of rna-seq data
and
the participants then will get their
first hands-on
assignment in this session on the
patient-derived xenograph data set
and we will also be sharing additional
resources
reading material for all the algorithms
that you saw there
in transcriptomics one so this will be
also a review session and an interactive
session
to know if you have any problems or if
you have any confusion
if you are getting somewhere stuck so
things like that
and after this in this week
we will start exploring the basic coding
so for those who are interested in
coding can
uh are could uh join this and
we will be able to do this coding in our
code
platform so uh in this
we will be doing uh from loading data
to some of the downstream analysis so
basically it would be a very basic
overview of
how to uh export files and how to
load that data using the code platform
so this week we will be learning how to
visualize
summarize and analyze data from
processing pipeline
so uh in transcriptomics like starting
from
march 12th on march 12th it will be we
will be trans
move will be moving from you know uh
table of expression
and the basic analysis to more
statistical analysis
so this transcriptomics too would be
more about you know understanding at a
statistical level that how
your data is i mean what your data says
and what is the what are the noise
how we can remove the noise and find the
meaning out of those out of that
out of the experiment that we have got
so one of the limitations
in this sort of high speed data
generation
is the amount of noise and amount of um
you know non-essential data that we get
so one of the key uh
key skills that comes from this sort of
experience is to
be able to learn about your
data and visualize it when you have
generated it so that your downstream
analysis makes sense
so some of these techniques are used to
study
the variation so we will be using gene
expression matrix then you can
that can be used to study the variation
so some of these techniques are really
easy
it's not that tough some of these
techniques are easy to use
and can be done in excel and we'll be
going through that in our sessions
and which will be recorded and sent out
via email
so we will be using either excel or some
table manipulation software
and some of the other approaches which
are more streamlined approaches those
will be used
using the tbi info cloud
so in transcriptomics 2 during this this
week
we will be learning about more complex
algorithms and we will be using some of
the statistical algorithms like t-test
and then the um the online session
that will supplement this uh course
transcriptomics 2 module
it describes a number of statistical
techniques
typically used for simpler and then more
complex approaches to find
differentially expressed genes so
once the data is you know standardized
and
prepared we will learn about what about
working the
identified genes to arrive at a
biological interpretation of results
so ultimately it's not just about the
data
but also how to prepare it we want to
gain a biological
uh you know in our objective here is to
gain a
understanding or a biological
understanding of the project
so connecting the data elements with
their biological significance
will be a major focus of this program
so in the week in the third week when we
have this
understanding of how statistics work
what is there to look into the data we
will be focusing on differential gene
expression
so one of the major objective of doing
transcriptomics research
is sometimes and most of the time is to
learn about the differential gene
expression
and we will be continue we'll continue
to look and
look at typical challenges that can be
resolved
using other methods so we will use a t
test then we will use
d62 to run a differential gene
expression pipeline
and then we will use uh in the next
session
we will learn about the first uh machine
learning method
which is uh the factor regression
analysis
so it's a regression based algorithm
so in this session uh after
doing this after learning this as a
result you will be able to detect
obvious differences between preset
groups
as well as the expand the idea of more
subtle differences
presented by factors that might interact
with
each other so when i'm talking about
multi-dimensional data
then you will see that that
data has multiple features so if you
get a data for uh for example for a
liver cancer
sample then you will you might find that
that there are
uh there are different factors that
influences liver cancer so it's not so
simple that
there is a direct connection but there
are multiple factors that influences
one connection and to understand about
that the statistical analysis that will
be used is factor regression analysis
so uh as i was telling you that we will
be working on data sets throughout this
throughout this program so we'll discuss
the property of such data sets where
thousands of observations about each
sample
contributes to noise and misleading data
some aspects of log normal distribution
and adjusted p
value they are accounted for false
discovery rate will be explained in
detail
so for our next session on friday march
19th uh that will be dedicated to
advanced
analytical methods advanced analysis
methods of transcriptomics data
that allows us to find meaningful
pattern in big data sets
especially complex patterns that are
very typical for
rna-seq experiments for example i mean
pca pca can help us understand
variability between samples
by analyzing all of our data features so
we can use such dimensionality reduction
techniques
to get a better better insight better
insights
into our data set and to be able to
visualize it
so by comparing multiple methods and by
plotting them
we will also learn about
we can study genes so as a result we can
study genes
and how they describe how the how they
are described
in samples so samples are maybe the
patient samples
in our data set and how this correlates
with phenotypic information we have
for biological or even clinical
interpretation
so we will learn about impact of feature
selection on interpretation of
conditions sampled on various data sets
so after exploring different methods for
identifying
groups of samples without prior
knowledge
so when we don't have a prior knowledge
we call it unsupervised machine learning
and when we have a prior knowledge we
call it supervised machine learning
so one of the example of unsupervised
machine learning is clustering
so in week 4 we will examine methods for
developing
classifiers for known samples which is
predictive analysis or classification so
in the next week after learning about
unsupervised machine learning
we will be learning about approaches
such as
machine learning and data mining and
predictive analysis
uh using algorithms to
to learn about how they connect and how
they give us
what important information that we are
asking from the data set
so to do that we will cover uh decision
trees and random forest to work with
various gene sets for classification
for example a defined pattern of
expression can be
linked to you know regulatory network
affected by a condition so this could be
one of the things that you get
out of this sort of research so for
example we will
learn to utilize gene set expression and
gene set enrichment analysis
to find pathways or gene set enriched
which are like either upregulated or
down regulated
and are are our genes of our interest
so during this entire exercise of
learning about machine learning
algorithms you will be learning about
dimensions
classes and features which are helping
us
understand how these machine learning
algorithms can be
applied to offer interpretable results
so application wise uh after learning
after
you saw this is like a journey you start
from basic
understanding basic data analysis then
you
trans then you move uh towards the
second area to more advanced statistical
analysis and then you move to a further
advanced analysis of
using machine learning and now that how
this entire research field can be
applied to various areas of
research so sorry
so these methods are not always used in
smaller research projects
however they have much more important
application
in both pharma and biotech r d
as well as in clinical applications so
mastering these methods will
help you understand for example in
clinical application or in biomedical
research you can think about biomarker
discovery and patient stratification
both of which uses uh predictive
modeling and feature selection
so here today uh we have a very
uh specialized person dr harpreet car
with us
how she has done her entire phd and have
published uh
amazing papers on some of the aspects of
ngs data and machine learning
so now i like to pass it on to dr
harpreet to guide us
uh and talk more about bioinformatics
projects
and application of ngs data and that
that what would we
be doing in the second phase of this
training uh
in the week five onwards so
over to you dr harpreet thank you doctor
and yeah please feel free to ask
questions
regarding whatever i have shared so i'll
be happy to answer them in the chat
and we will have a q a session towards
the end as well
thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics in my
current role i am omiks logic
bioinformatics trainer
with pine biotech i am assisting
participants to learn about data
analysis
machine learning and visualization in
the application to the last data set
used in the biomedical research beside i
am involved in designing different
research projects using publicly
available data
so the upcoming omics logic program will
be focused on
transcriptomics we will discuss the
various aspects of rna-seq data analysis
and how this field can be
applied to the various suspect and
continuously growing
in the health care so during this
program
you will learn about how you can design
your own
independent research project based on
publicly
available and js transcriptomics data
and
employing various bioinformatics
techniques
so today we will perform various ngs
data analysis
using the data sets based on basin drive
genograph project
so now let's understand what is a pdx
project or pdx model
so a pdx models are generated when a
fresh tumor
fresh tissue obtained directly from the
basin
and is implanted subcutaneously and
ortho topically into the immune
deficient mice
so as these models maintain the
principle histological
clinical and molecular characteristics
of the original basin tumor samples
while remaining biologically stable
since these pdx models are more closely
resemble and
recapitulate the tumor growth in human
then standard in vitro cell line so they
remain
key experimental platform for
pre-clinical drug development
so today we will try to analyze two
breast cancer subtypes using pdx model
the breast cancer types include er
positive
and triple negative so this er positive
breast cancer have a special type of
receptor that is estrogen receptors
while the triple negative breast cancer
lacks
all the three common receptor on its
membrane
so this is just a one difference that
makes
triple negative is a more aggressive
form of breast cancer
while ear remains a more treatable form
so now let's go over to the server and
let's run
an example pipeline here we will learn
how we can generate a gene expiration
well structured gene expression data
table
from raw sequencing read data
so let's move over move over t band for
server
so beeps if you share this
okay thank you
so on this interface you will find
various sections for different types of
analysis
like already dr mohit has shown you we
have
ng state analysis then mass spec
analysis then structure biology
then data integration and
modeling so under the ng uh ngs data
section
here we have a subsection that is
dedicated to the transcriptomics
so once you are on this server so here
you will find a different analysis
pipeline
so today i am going to demonstrate a
simple example pipeline
that is from the pdx project so on
here under the rna see see can cheap
parallel analysis of ngs and microarray
data
here if we click on the drop down you
will get this
demo rnac pdx project
so i'm clicking on this as this is a
demonstration pipeline so we have
already uploaded example data set that
is raw sequencing data
so by clicking on the start
we will able to upload this data so here
we have already provided the reference
genome file
and as well as we have created the sql
links
for the fastq files and we have
submitted that files here
and once we click on ok be able to
submit upload these files so then the
next option that is getting highlighted
that is under the pre-processing
so the next option which getting
highlighted here is trimomatic so what
it does
it will removes adapters from your raw
sequencing read data
so eventually it will remove all the
non-technical sequence and we
are come up with only read sequences
so then the next step which is getting
highlighted here that is pcr clean
so what this pcr clean will do that
it will going to remove your pcr
duplicates
as during uh before
during the generation of rna-seq
analysis
so we used to uh done the pcr
amplification
so it will remove all the pcr duplicates
so then the next options that are
getting alignment once you got the clean
deeds
the next is how you are going to
align your reads against a reference
genome
or reference transcriptome as here our
goal
is to generate a gene expression data
table from the rnec
so we are mapping our reads against a
transcriptome so for that we are using
this mapping algorithm that is but i
2t so
here what it does it will align your
reads against the reference
transcriptome
by clicking on ok we will execute that
step
then up after the mapping of a reads on
a reference transcriptome
next is quantification of your reads
so here we are using this rsem
expression
algorithm so with this algorithm
we will able to generate a gene
expression table on which you can
perform various kind of
uh analysis so this particular rscm
which is also known as rna-seq using
expectation maximization
algorithm so this software will
eventually quantify
your expression in the form of ftkm
rpkm or tpm depending upon your input
rates
so then here i am also executing the
another analysis that is differential
gene expression analysis so once we will
have a gene expression table then we can
also perform differential gene
expression and this is
so here we have different algorithm
right now i am using the dsec2
so it will perform the differential
expression analysis between the
these two condition that is er positive
and triple negative breast cancer type
so then we can and this pipeline by
clicking on and we will able to complete
this pipeline
so once your pipeline will uh get
completed
then under the download pipeline output
files you will get here
all the outputs so the first output that
i am going to show you
that is how the gene expression table
so let me just download this gene
expression table
so this is the gene expression table
that we have obtained after running this
dsec pipeline
so let me just paste it in the excel so
now we have
this gene expression table where our
samples are in the columns while in the
row we have ensembl ids for the
transcripts
again for the genes so here you will get
like ear positive sample then you will
have at the end you will have a triple
negative sample
so this is the first outcome that we
have obtained after running this
pipeline where we have obtained
gene expression table in the form of pkm
values
where you can perform various kind of
analysis so then
the second output that we have obtained
if you have observed
as we had also also executed desect
analysis
so we will also get the uh output for
that so
if you download this folder that is
desect all pipe chips
so then we will able to obtain
this folder so here you will have a
different output so the first output i
would like to show you
that is
this table desect table the results from
the
dsec analysis
as dr mohit has already shown you that
the most important thing uh point is uh
identifying the important
genes that can differentiate between two
different conditions so this is what the
table we will obtain
so like here we have
first in the first row we have genes
then we have the in the third row like
here
we have log to fold chains then in the
last column we have p
adjusted value so then we can identify
only
important significant genes by filtering
out
these genes by based on the p adjusted
value
so uh the significant the p value which
is considered as significant
that is p value less than 0.05 so you
then you can filter out only
important chain so this is the one
another analysis that you can run
so apart from the differential gene
expression analysis and the uh
obtaining the table so once we have this
gene expression table
so the other analysis that we can
perform that is we should able to
to normalize this data
so this is what the kind of gene
expression table that we have obtained
after running the this rna-seq pipeline
so during this program you will learn
various uh how you can
execute various exploratory data
analysis
but to perform any explorative data
analysis your expression
data must be normalized so as it is well
known fact that most of the statistics
methods
can be applied on a data that follow
normal distribution
so when looking at like original data
here
the um of this a large number of samples
will be look like outliers so this type
of distribution will interfere with many
of the statistical tests
or machine learning algorithm analysis
so to reduce this wide range of variance
uh variation
we need to perform normalization of the
data
so like after applying the normalization
we can actually derive
a significant meaning from this data so
thus we will learn about different
methods
to normalize transcript transcriptomics
data
like log scale transformation or the
quantile normalization
so next to understand the pattern of the
distribution of the sample within our
data
we can perform various types of
exploratory data analysis
so there are number of the exploratory
data analysis
available like number of the
unsupervised as well as supervised
algorithm
so let me demonstrate how you can
perform principle com
component analysis as well as quantile
normalization
on your data once you have a table using
this simple t
band for platform so let let me go again
on t
band for server
so here under the area analysis we can
again directly to the
first interface so here under the data
mining you will find different
options like supervised unsupervised
utility factor analysis
then differential gene expression
analysis so as i am interested to
perform
quantile normalization as well as pca so
i am taking the example of this
demo utility pca
so here already we have uploaded this
data
uh that we have obtained from the
rna-seq pipeline
so then by clicking on ok we able to
upload this data
then the next step is quantile
normalization
so then here we are mainly executing two
steps first we are converting our
fpkm value into the log scale and then
we are transforming these value
into the uh quantile normalized using a
threshold five
so we are clicking on that okay
be able to perform quantile
normalization once we have normalized
data
now we can uh perform various
exploratory data analysis
so right now i am performing principal
component analysis that is pca
so by clicking on ok be able to perform
that
by ending be able to complete this
pipeline
so here under the output
we will get these results let me just
show you this pca plot results
similarly
so here so these are this plot ways we
can draw later as well
so here we have obtained the pca
components like here the first component
here
it contribute nearly 30 variation in the
data
then the pca2 pca2 component that
contribute nearly 14 percent variation
in the data so
by taking this uh these two components
we can
draw a pca plot or scatter plot
sorry
just give me a second
just give me a second
so then we can draw a scatter plot to
understand the pattern
so like this one so then we can actually
go
mark them and plot something like this
so here based on the pca plot we can
visualize
the difference between the two classes
of the sample
that is er positive and triple negative
besides because this particular data set
also have
mice models that is a timing and the not
so we can
draw the pattern for that as well so
this is how you can draw pca plots
simply using this pca
uh pipeline and then
the next platform apart from that but
our
script coding how this scripts are
working behind
so then we have the another platform
that is codomix logic
so if you are on this platform here
under the courses you will find
different courses
how each of these scripts work so the
for example
first i am going through the one of the
pca
pipeline so here in the course you will
find the different lessons
for each type of analysis like data
visualization
then dimensionality reduction then
differential gene expression analysis
and clustering as well
so if i go to the one of this lesson
that is dimensionality reduction by pca
so in this each of these lesson you will
find a different subsections
so here the first step will provide
give you the detailed introduction like
what you are going to perform
so then in the once you able to complete
that
in the second part that is learn the
code here you will
learn how this script is working so how
you can write your own code so what each
step is doing you will get
that information so once you're able to
learn this code
in the next section you will
you will try it yourself so for example
i am taking
this pc plot here first we are loading a
libraries that is a required
package then we are loading our data
each step
is written with the hash exactly but the
next step is doing
so then we are taking only the data that
contain
without only numerical data so then we
have performed
a piece principle component analysis
using prc com function
so then once be able to perform pca then
how we can plot
for example first we are going to
perform simple pca plot
then we are also creating uh we also
adding colors
then we are also adding the frames and
then you can also add the
labels that is what are these samples so
by clicking on run you can
you able to execute this code
so like here we have obtained different
plots so let me just show you like this
is with this example data
so the first you will get like plot like
this where you can
how your samples are distributed
so then you can also draw up
frames against each of these
subtypes like here we have different
groups like
this is from the breast cancer cell line
data which have
four breast cancer subtypes that is
basal chlorine low luminal and normal
life
so how we can visualize the differences
between
these samples so this pc plot will help
you to do that so on codomics you will
learn to execute
code so then under another section where
you can modify these codes according to
your own analysis so
now let's let me go back to the
presentation
so this is how you can generate your pca
plots
so this is about the codomix platform
so the in the last week to provides
hands-on training and to make
participants familiar with the approach
to design
and complete a research project we are
continuously designing different
research projects
using publicly available data
based on a studies published in high
impact journals
thus we have a collection of research
projects
where you can learn how bioinformatics
can be applied in the field of
various fields of
health care using publicly available
data to drive
biological and clinical important
signatures
so let me give you an example of the
liver cancer project
here we have explored different omics
data types that
is rna and mi rna in clinical
clinical and demographic data employing
multi-omics data integration
approach for the liver cancer patient to
find out the molecular signature that
are associated with clinical phenotypes
of the liver cancer patients
as one of the major challenge with this
malignancy
is that a single omics data is not
sufficient to design
high highly efficient biomarker thus
multi omics data types can fill out that
lacuna
and will facilitate to design efficient
signatures
but then another major challenge is the
integration of those multi-omics data
types
either you need to develop an individual
pipeline for each data type then you
will
find an approach or a method to
integrate them together
for this you required high computational
and bioinformatics
skills so to remove those obstacles
various multi-omics data integration
tools like
snf iclusterplus go to pls on a t-band
for server
but integrated peer users just need to
provide input
data set and can easily perform various
types of multi-omics analysis by just
clicking on option as i have shown you
in demonstration
so in this project we have also used
these multi-omics data
tools to find out important signatures
so finally we uh we have fire
we have tried to multi-omics data
integration that can provide us
holistic picture of this lethal
malignancy and how the
how they are associated with diverse
clinical phenotype like
tumor stage risk factors is gender of
the patients
so participant can explore this project
beside
we have another project on covid19
so in this project you will explore
about this pathogen corona virus itself
as well as the disease caused by
it then you will learn about its origin
and how
much it is related with already existing
human coronavirus streams
using ngs data and bioinformatics
methods
next you will also see what important
components of the virus through which
they enter into the human cell
and finally you will see how you can
identify
important transcriptomic signatures that
can significantly different
are significantly different under
therapeutic treatment
and untreated conditions
then you will also get and project over
alzheimer's disease
so as we know alzheimer is one of uh is
a complex neurodegenerative disease
caused by
several genetic and epigenetic factor so
these are
driven by genetic variations changes in
the gene expression as well as the
other omics data types so here you will
learn on this project you will learn
how you can obtain a data from data set
from public repository and
execute different types of analysis
so in the later part of this training
program you will
need to submit a research proposal so
here
you need to define various fields like
project title that is
your research questions then you have to
define you need to define your exact
research
statement then you need to provide
project summary that you need to
define what is your expected outcome and
then
what are what are the different method
methods that you can employ
and then you need to provide the data
set that you can use and
as well as the reference publications
so in the past there are a number of the
research fellows
who have completed their research
project in the diverse fields
based on ngs transcriptomics
bioinformatics with the pine biotic
research fellowship program so among
them
one of our research for fellow mr kalau
mari maril
who is a phd student from mexico city
he's recently completed his research
project
entitled classification of triple
negative breast cancer cell line
by gene expression analysis of the
transmembrane protein
using various types of machine learning
algorithm
that are able integrated on t band for
servo
and based on available cell line data
employing these tools
then we have another research we had
another
research fellow miss semi dollar
a undergraduate student student from the
turkey
recently completed her research project
entitled long non-coding
rna as therapeutic target in chronic
lymphocyte leukemia using publicly
available data
from cll and employing different tools
from the t-bind for server
so i'm looking forward to become a
research
trainer and i now i would like to pass
this session
to miss beeps to talk about registration
process
and more about this program so over to
you beeps are
thank you so much uh dr harpreet
so let me introduce you to the different
program resources as well as some of the
free resources we have
for all of our participants that you can
start
learning from right away so for
different parts of this one-month
program we leverage our mix logic
resources
that will include the asynchronous
courses as dr mohit has shown
the cloud-based analytical server where
you can analyze
large rna-seq data as well as visualize
the results as dr hartreet was
demonstrating to you
the omixlogic code breakdown where you
can practice coding in rn python as well
as a repository
of project examples so to do this
the first platform that we have is the
edut buying for platform
and let us together go and see this
platform
so please come with me to hyphen bio dot
info so in this
platform uh this is a free login and
once you log into this platform
you will have a membership to the free
resources for a lifetime
so this is the edut by info platform
and here is a free resource that if you
have not
already taken i would invite you all to
go ahead it's the introduction to
bioinformatics course
and this course will introduce you to
the different areas of application of
bioinformatics
so if you are someone who is new to our
bioinformatics community
we invite you all to go ahead and
take this course this course will give
you an overview
and it starts with an introductory
survey this survey is very helpful
for us to understand what are your areas
of research interest
and where do you want to go forward with
the kind of bioinformatics training
you're looking for
so please go through this course if you
have not already taken it
and help us learn more about you and
talking about what dr harpreet has
already shown you
as part of this program as part of the
omics logic training
addition to the courses you have access
to different projects right so
here is a project on tuberculosis that
manisha has been asking about
so you can see so these projects are
available to all participants or part of
the omix logic programs
if you want to take this project as you
see there is a cost
for uh for the projects to be taken if
you're doing them
separately but for all participants of
any of our programs
many of these projects are included
depending on the kind of omits logic
training
you are going through so there are
different projects here
on ebola on cancer that we will be
taking examples for in this one month
training
and the next step as dr harpied shows
is to come up with your own project
proposal
so as this is a one month training we
understand there is not enough time to
come up with a full fledged project
but what we would hope and we help
help you do is come up with your own
project proposal
and i'm going to be sharing with you
some examples
so these are examples from people and
participants who have taken
these kinds of projects and done it
themselves
so these were all done in our research
fellowship program which is the next
step
where once you complete a training
program the next step is to develop your
own research project
so all of these projects that you would
find on this page has been
proposed by the participants and then
they have worked very closely
with our mentor team to work on these
projects
so you will see different examples from
participants
who come from different levels of
education so we have
high school students who are doing these
projects as
well as we have phds and post doctorates
who are doing these kinds of projects
utilizing
public domain data sets for different to
answer different kinds of biological
questions so you're welcome to go
through this free resource
and going back so what do you gain
at the end of this one month training
program
you will receive a certificate so we
give out
two different certificates here is an
example of a certificate of excellence
which was given to one of our
participants from our previous program
that we had in last year so the
certificate of excellence is given to
anybody who has over 10
000 points so all of the courses
and the server platform as well as the
codemix logic platform
are connected to each other so we are
able to see your progress
over time and learn more from
you and your activity like what you are
doing and
by that way we are able to determine
your progress
and work with you to help you learn more
from
this entire training so we also give out
a certificate of completion
and the minimum requirement for that is
to at least have three thousand points
which is very easy
you would have to do a few courses and
run a few basic pipelines to get those
points and then what i have here
are examples from participants who have
already gone through trainings like this
so urja here you will find her example
under the project example link that i
have shared
she has completed her research project
on differential identification of
biomarkers between neural stem cells and
glioblastoma stem cells
and done that project and is now going
forward and presenting that project at
different student
conferences and also helping
and working towards her own publications
so these are the different opportunities
that you have so
what you do with your project is
completely open and up to you so you are
able to take
forward this training whatever you are
learning through this experience
and then explore the different areas you
can go and apply for a new position
you can start learning more about
rna-seq you can apply the knowledge to a
project
so you have several different examples
of other participants who have taken
these training
and then gone ahead and applied them
one competitions for example anurak
uh collaborated with arva bora
a training program and then they went
ahead
to win a pool team challenge so there
are these
different opportunities which are
available to you
so you all can go ahead and explore and
now i would want to invite you
all to go ahead and also
start joining us on our social media so
if you're already there with us
linked to our linkedin page and our
facebook group
so let me share the links to both of
these
pages very quickly in a minute
because in our linkedin page if you see
in our linkedin group
then you'll find that there are a lot of
participants who are joining us from all
over the globe
so if i see everybody here there are not
only
students who are joining us but there
are also other researchers are also
faculty so it is a community of
bioinformatics interests it's a
community of people who have
similar interests so you are able to
meet together
at one place so this is the
linkedin group and i'll post it again in
the chat box
for everyone who is interested in
joining
and we also have a similar group in
facebook for those of you who are
interested and i will be posting this
again
in the chat box so please go ahead and
join these
different groups and now regarding the
question about
how to join this training program
so this is the link of how to
register for this training program and
i'll also explain the different steps
so i'll post the link again in the chat
box here
so if you go to this link you will be
able to find the
different syllabus for this program it
has
all the program dates and the different
topics that we have also covered in this
session
and if you click on get started you will
be given three options
and let me explain to you what the three
options are
if you are just a beginner and us just
getting started
with by info matrix and learning about
edges data analysis
we recommend you the beginner option
this covers
all the basic training program as well
as
the research projects and giving your
proposal
during this entire one month training
while the intermediate option comes with
one
additional aspect which is you get
mentor support during the part of the
training whereas you can request
one-on-one mentor sessions beyond a
group session
so we have these different dates as you
saw where we will be meeting in an
online class like this and talking to
you about different topics so beyond
those sessions
if you are interested in taking extra
mentor help
you can also go for that intermediate
license the advanced license is
recommended
for anybody who wishes to work on a
project
the advanced license gives you two
months instead of just
one month it gives you two months which
is an extra 30 days
access and you will also get an advanced
license where you are
able to work with your own data sets if
you want
or you're also able to work with our
team of research fellows as well as our
own omixlogic trainers to work on your
own projects so
this will give you the two-month option
so these are the different
payment option we will also share with
you
some discount codes which are available
for the program
and you can register for this from right
here
and we also have another option for
students and participants who would
require
some kind of scholarship so we do have a
scholarship
option as well so if you are someone who
who requires the scholarship you can
also fill up the scholarship form at the
bottom of the page we do have some
prerequisites
which you need to offer we will meet
with you will discuss
and we only offer these scholarships to
students who are deserving
so we'll have that meeting with you and
we'll decide whether you
get a scholarship for this training
program
or a discount so we'll let you know as
we do the scholarship meetings with you
so these are the different ways you can
opt for this
training program and once you are in the
training
you will gain access to a page like this
it's called a forum page
which will have all the additional uh
details about how to get to the
different aspects
so this is just an example of what the
forum looks like
it has the event dates it has some
description about the program you will
also get to learn about the other
participants who are
joining along with you we welcome
collaborations and we hope that you are
able to collaborate with each other
on projects on discussing about
different topics
and make it a collaborative environment
and we have a forum option here
so that all the participants besides the
sessions are able
to come up and ask their questions
ask the questions to the mentor team so
that they're able to answer those
questions for you
post any other interesting topics that
you find we also share the top
participants here from time to time
so these are the different aspects of
the training program
and we are also able to see the
different progresses
for different participants who are part
of a training
from right from this organization page
so i welcome you all again
to go ahead and join this training
program
i'll be posting this in the chat box and
if you have
any questions please reach out to me at
marketing and find out bio
and now i would want to ask you all if
you have
any questions please let us know
so that we are able to answer those
questions for you
so is there any specific question that
you would want to ask us
or our team here and we can answer them
for you
so the chat box is open for questions
and
i will also you will also be able to
unmute yourself and ask
any questions that you have to our
mentors directly
regarding any of the aspects that we
were
talking about today so please post your
questions either in the chat box
or let us know
we hope that this program is going to be
helpful for both students
as well as clinicians and researchers
and this is the reason we have the
training designed this way where we
start with very basics
so that if you just have a very basic
idea of
cell and molecular biology you are able
to join the training
understand those basic concepts and then
build up
slowly given with the different tools
and resources that we have shown you
as part of the training program
and i hope i don't see any questions
today
so i want to thank you all for joining
this session
and yes the timing for the program
is 5 p.m indian standard time which is
the same time as this webinar today
so you are able to see all of the
different sessions starting from march
2nd
the different sessions all those
sessions will be
on 5 pm uh indian standard time
to 6 pm so if you have any other
questions related
to the program you can ask us again
and thank you all
for joining today so manisha you are
asking can the timing be
5 30 pm ist for now the sessions have
already been designed so
if you cannot join the session on time
is there any other
option of course so what we do is that
like today's session we record all of
these sessions
every day and we have a private youtube
channel where we put it so
only participants have access to those
links
we share it with all participants after
each of the session is
over every day along with the
assignments and any other details that
we have discussed during the session
so in case you're interested in joining
this training program now
we will keep it open and you can
actually go forward
and join the training session and if
you're missing out on some of the
classes you will receive the recording
for that
as it is a one month training and we'll
go week by week
so you will be able to learn from these
different
sessions and you can also review them at
your leisure during the weekends or any
other time that you have
and will definitely consider if you have
any other requests regarding the timing
so you can if
a lot of people agree that it could be
done
at a different time then we definitely
can so we had actually done a poll on
instagram
where we got this idea that many people
are free at around 5 p.m indian standard
time
so we had done that last month and we
got that answer that
a lot of the participants are interested
in doing a session at 5 00 pm
so we asked your community and we got
that answer so we have
designed the sessions to be at this
point of time
but we are definitely open to any other
requests that you may have and we'll try
to consider
them so i hope that we have been able to
answer all of these questions
we'll have more webinars as well as more
sessions
in the upcoming weeks so please follow
the email
which is marketing and find on bio for
any other information regarding this
and i thank you all again for joining
today's session
have a lovely weekend everyone
you